alors j'avais envie de vous faire une
hardy view mais comme c'est vous je vous
faire une entière d'idiot alors il va je
ne pensé pas quoi en ce moment je pense
pas que je suis en train de regarder des
conneries à la télévision dans mon
canapé puisque je suis dedans quand vous
regardez le matin dans la glace vous ne
vous dit jamais quoi je me dis jamais
que j'aimerais être sarkozy en train de
me dire que je veux être président de la
république c'est sûr vous n'auriez pas
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petits à qui j'aurais pas aimé
ressembler pour l'été petit aux truands
qui voulaient flinguer gary cooper dans
le train sifflera trois fois
qu'est-ce que vous ne quittez riez pas
pour le grand amour
la grande amitié quand on vous demande
une autographes vous ne signez jamais
quoi thierry ardisson vous garderiez
coise en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique bas la baguette magique
quel est le péché qui vous tente le
moins l'avarice jeu pourriez vous dire
de plus positif sur vos dans une
discussion
j'aime bien que les autres aient raison
comme ça j'apprends quelque chose si
votre vie était à refaire vous ne
changeriez pas quoi la liberté que j'ai
aujourd'hui dans ma vie et dans mon
boulot qui n'avez vous jamais eu envie
d'épater joe cooker j'ai pu faire parce
que c'est un chanteur génial et je
préfère que celui qui continuaient mais
pas telle quelle quelle est la chose que
vous ne faites jamais avant de vous
coucher mettre un pyjama ou non et et le
diable dans tout ça
c'est un ami exigeant qu'est ce qui ne
vous énerve pas du tout chez moi votre
cravate qu'est ce que vous n'avez pas
envie koch la vérité qu'est ce que la
vie ne nous a toujours pas après la
méfiance
comment n'aimeriez vous pas mourir en
ayant peur de mourir
qui auriez vous aimé ne pas voir ici ce
soir
j'imagine que si j'aurais pas aimé voir
ici ce soir je sais pas vraiment les
gens qui pensent que qui avait pas
d'avion sur le pentagone
11 septembre on n'est pas passé loin
d'un risque il faudra vérifier
faut-il être quelqu'un d'autre que soi
même
bah parfois vous en savez quelque chose
un oui à quel signe reconnaissez-vous
infailliblement l'intelligence la
gentillesse il ya une belle bande de
contre existe-t-il une personne que vous
agissiez au point de souhaiter de
survivre pinochet truc quelle somme
accepteriez-vous de manger un bol de
caviar